Dueling volcanos and rival
expeditions to Mars. Would
you believe that these very similar
movies were released back to back?
All the way back in 1883, Italian author
Carlo Collodi shared his best known work,
"The Adventures of Pinocchio," with the
world. In the 140 years since it received
its first literary release, the story
of the living puppet has been adapted
almost too many times to count, with
Disney's 1940 animated classic being
perhaps the most well known. So
why was 2022 the year of Pinocchio?
First came the simply titled "Pinocchio"
in September, Disney's live-action remake
of their own animated classic. Helmed
by acclaimed filmmaker Robert Zemeckis,
who's known for "Back to the Future" and
"Forrest Gump," it stars Tom Hanks as Geppetto,
Joseph Gordon-Levitt as Jiminy Cricket, and
Benjamin Evan Ainsworth as Pinocchio himself.
Unfortunately, this outing didn't quite
reach the lofty status of the original,
falling flat on its face with critics and
audiences alike despite some impressive visuals.
Not long after, Mexican filmmaker Guillermo
del Toro released his own spin on the tale
with the help of Netflix — and this
one arrived to a much warmer reception
and an Academy Award for Best Animated
Feature. Putting his signature dark
fantasy twist on the story, which was
brought to life entirely in stop-motion,
Del Toro lends an undeniable charm to the
adaptation. "Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio"
features the talents of Ewan McGregor, Tilda
Swinton, Cate Blanchett, and Finn Wolfhard.
How many more adaptations of Pinocchio
will make their way to streaming services
over the next few years? We'll
just have to see for ourselves.
"Oh, hi! It's me!"
(rabbits grumble)
"I cannot die!"
"We know!"
"I can't die!"
Westerns have a long tradition of playing with
iconic trademarks — but in 1991, audiences were
given two strikingly similar entries to the
genre: "Tombstone" and "Wyatt Earp." Arriving
exactly six months apart from one another, both
films focused on the gunfight at the O.K. Corral,
which saw the Earp brothers and Doc Holliday
face off against the feared Clanton-McLaury
gang. As is often the case when two related
titles duke it out in theaters, the first
to reach the masses is generally considered the
winner in the fight for dominance. In this case,
that proved doubly true: "Tombstone"
didn't just win the box office battle,
but it has since gone on to be remembered
as one of the best Westerns of all time.
While both films dedicate significant
screen time to the infamous gunfight,
the biggest difference between the two is their
approach. As the name suggests, the focus in
"Tombstone" is entirely on the events that led to
the bloody day in the town of Tombstone, Arizona,
and it's rounded out with an impeccable cast
that includes big names like Kurt Russell,
Val Kilmer, and Sam Elliott. On the other hand,
"Wyatt Earp" was more focused on depicting the
broader life of Earp in its entirety. Starring
Kevin Costner in the titular role, this version
shows us everything from Earp's adolescence
during the Civil War to his life in the years
after the bloodbath in Arizona. It simply wasn't
nearly as big of a hit with critics or audiences.
On a fateful fall night in 1959, four members
of the Clutter family were brutally murdered by
home invaders Richard Hickock and Perry Smith.
The brutal nature of the crime — as well as the
ensuing manhunt for the suspects — led famed
author Truman Capote to the town of Holcomb,
Kansas, where he found inspiration to begin
writing his groundbreaking novel "In Cold
Blood." Widely considered to be the author's
best work, it's credited with kickstarting the
true crime genre, and it remains compelling to
this day. Nearly 40 years after its publication,
the story of Capote's struggle to write the
book saw two film adaptations made back to back.
Starring Philip Seymour Hoffman in the lead role,
the fittingly titled "Capote" follows the author
as he researches the grisly case in Kansas,
with a focus on his time spent with killer
Perry Smith, played by Clifton Collins
Jr. A by-the-numbers drama performed to the
highest degree, "Capote" earned itself an
impressive five Academy Award nominations
and snagged a Best Actor win for Hoffman.
"You think that was too much?"
"A little bit!"
[laughing]
Despite being incredibly similar by
nature of telling the same story,
the competing biopic "Infamous" — starring
Toby Jones and Daniel Craig — strays from
its competition with a more down-to-earth
tone. Although it's a capable retelling
of the author's life, "Infamous"
struggled to escape from under the
shadow of "Capote," and never quite
achieved the same level of success.
In the summer of 1997, NASA's Sojourner rover
landed on the planet Mars, becoming the first
successful touchdown on the Red Planet in over
20 years. With Mars now on the public's mind,
filmmakers scrambled to capitalize on
the wave of interest, with "Mission to
Mars" making its own landing just before
the spring of 2000. Directed by Brian De
Palma and featuring a solid cast including
Don Cheadle, Tim Robbins, and Gary Sinise,
the film is set during humanity's first
manned journey to the planet Mars.
Unfortunately for the crew, the pioneering
venture soon runs into catastrophe,
which is exactly the same fate that awaited
the crew in "Red Planet" when it made its own
landing in November of the same year.
A much more bleak look at our future,
"Red Planet" tells of a near-future Earth on
its last legs due to a prolonged climate crisis,
leading humanity to seek refuge on Mars.
Val Kilmer stars as the leader of the crew
of the "Mars-1," a ship sent to the
titular celestial body in a desperate
attempt to preserve the future of the human
race. Of course, things go terribly wrong.
Like both movie missions to our cosmic neighbor,
the twin films themselves were outright disasters.
In addition to struggling at the ticket counter,
"Red Planet" and "Mission to Mars"
were met with equally poor reviews.
The oddly similar animated kids movies "Despicable
Me" and "Megamind" got their cinematic releases in
2010, with both films subverting the superhero
formula by focusing on diabolical villains as
opposed to the good guys. The first of the two
to appear on the silver screen was "Despicable
Me," which saw Steve Carrell play Gru: a
comical baddie who adopts three plucky girls.
"So good night, sleep tight,
and don't let the bedbugs bite… because
there are literally thousands of them."
Aided by his horde of bright yellow
— and highly marketable — minions,
it's not hard to see why "Despicable Me"
was such a hit with fans of all ages.
Dreamworks' effort "Megamind," though —
perhaps hoping to distance the film from
the competitive spring and summer release
windows — arrived in the comparably quieter
fourth quarter of that year. Telling the story of
the titular alien supervillain — voiced by Will
Ferrell — whose hubris causes him to switch
from villain to hero, the plucky comedy was
received well by most viewers. It earned a
respectable $300 million in ticket sales,
but was still roundly defeated at the box
office by "Despicable Me," which has since
received multiple spin-offs and sequels.
"Megamind" has struggled to get a sequel
off the ground since its release, with only
a follow-up small screen streaming series
currently in development — but it's still an
incredibly fun film with a cult following.
Long before "Despicable Me"
and "Megamind," another pair
of similar computer animated films took a
tussle in the dirt. It was the late '90s,
and Pixar had just burst onto the
scene with their massive hit "Toy
Story," the first feature film to be completely
computer animated. In an effort to keep up,
newly formed rival studio DreamWorks released a
CGI animated film of their own in October of 1998,
a family-friendly romp titled "Antz" — spelled
with a Z. Just over a month later, Pixar fired
back with their second feature, "A Bug's Life,"
a film that was remarkably similar to their
competitor's first offering. That made the fall
of '98 a season packed with bug-themed adventures.
These two might be the most similar on this list,
as both films follow an ant tasked with saving
their colony from certain doom. What's far more
interesting than the films themselves, though,
is the behind-the-scenes controversy that
cast a shadow over their releases. According
to a 1998 article in Entertainment Weekly, the
overlap between the two films was no accident.
"A Bug's Life" director John Lasseter accused
Jeffrey Katzenberg — DreamWorks co-founder and
former Disney chairman — of intentionally
trying to squash the success of "A Bug's
Life" with his own studio's "Antz" using inside
information. Highly controversial at the time,
it's somewhat surprising that
not all of the twin films on
this list had similar accusations of
plagiarism toward their productions.
"Don't follow orders your whole
life. Think for yourself."
In the late '90s, reality TV was taking off, and
Hollywood was taking notice. In quick succession,
a pair of major releases played off the idea
that a person could find themself the star of
their very own program — whether they like it
or not. "The Truman Show" was released first,
and it capped off a defining decade for Jim Carrey
by putting him in the role of typical suburbanite
Truman Burbank. Little does he know, however,
that his entire life has been lived under the
watchful eyes of television audiences around the
globe, and everything around him is an elaborate,
carefully-constructed false reality. It all comes
crashing down when Truman gets the idea to finally
leave his hometown, forcing the people in charge
to try and keep him from discovering the truth.
Following in its footsteps was director Ron
Howard's "EDtv" — starring Matthew McConaughey
as Edward Pekurny, the around-the-clock star of
his own reality television program. Unlike "The
Truman Show," there's no mystery to the plot. Ed
is — at least at first — a willing participant
to the producer's latest reality TV series, as
every step of his life is recorded for hungry home
viewers. But that lack of mystery, combined
with a plot that just felt like a repeat of
"The Truman Show," meant that "EDtv" just
couldn't win over the same audiences. Would
we still be talking about "EDtv" if it
had been released first? Maybe so — but
it's hard to disagree that "The Truman
Show" is definitely the better movie.
It may seem strange — and it is — but 1997 saw two
separate and unrelated biopics based
on the life of the 14th Dalai Lama,
but told from very different perspectives.
They arrived in the latter half of 1997,
with one becoming a box office hit, and the other
going on to become an under-appreciated gem.
Arriving in September that year was Jean-Jacques
Annaud's "Seven Years in Tibet," which focuses
on the life of Austrian mountaineer and
former SS member Heinrich Harrer, played
by Brad Pitt. Imprisoned in India by British
forces at the onset of the Second World War,
Heinrich eventually escapes, fleeing to
neighboring Tibet and quickly becoming immersed
in their way of life. It's there that he meets
the young Dalai Lama, befriending the spiritual
child leader as an impending conflict with the
Chinese government begins brewing on the horizon.
"Do you like movies?"
"You know, I haven't seen a movie in about
eight years, but as I recall, yes, very much."
A few months later, audiences would
return to Tibet with "Kundun." This time,
the plot was entirely focused on the Dalai Lama,
encompassing everything from his selection as
the spiritual leader to his eventual exile from
Tibet in 1959. Directed by Martin Scorsese and
reviewed more favorably than its predecessor,
"Kundun" was nominated for four Academy Awards
that year. It remains a seminal film on the
complicated relations between China and the region
of Tibet — even if it flopped at the box office.
Every year, cinemas are packed with
animal pictures perfect for audiences
looking for some family-friendly fun, and
there's no creature studios would rather
turn to than man's best friend.
In the spring and summer of 2019,
we got two eerily similar releases that
not only starred some lovable pups,
but even went a step further by having the
dogs themselves narrate the events on screen.
First up was "A Dog's Journey," released in
May of that year. The first feature film by
Gail Mancuso — perhaps best known for her work on
"Modern Family" and "30 Rock" — it's a sequel to
2017's emotional rollercoaster "A Dog's Purpose."
Picking up where the first entry left off,
it continues the story of Bailey across his many
canine lives, as he reunites with his owner time
and time again. Close behind was "The Art of
Racing in the Rain," which similarly follows
the ups and downs of a dog's life with his human
companion. Told in flashback, Kevin Costner voices
Enzo, an aging Golden Retriever looking back
on his racecar-driving owner, Denny. So which
heartstring-tugging puppy picture ended up winning
out? Both of these fuzzy flicks wound up in the
doghouse with critics, but "A Dog's Journey"
brought home a bit more loot at the box office.
Films and television are ripe with
adaptations of the Greek myth of Hercules,
with films as far back as the '50s and a
hit TV series starring Kevin Sorbo in the
'90s. The tale of the legendary warrior is a
timeless one — and in 2014, we got not one,
but two more films to add to the long list
of adaptations. Despite starring a pair of
well-known names, neither was able to match
the legend's strength when it came to quality.
The first in theaters was "The Legend of
Hercules," with Kellan Lutz starring as
the Greek hero as he embarks on an epic
quest for redemption. Universally panned,
the film couldn't even recoup its modest budget.
In the wake of that flop was the plainly titled
"Hercules," which featured Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson in the title role. Telling the story
of a latter day Hercules, the film follows the
aging hero as he wanders as an aimless mercenary.
When the kingdom of Thrace is threatened with
annihilation, Hercules is left with no choice
but to rise to the occasion, calling upon
his nearly forgotten strength and courage.
While neither film was particularly good,
Johnson's effort fared better at the box office,
likely aided by his superstar
name at the top of the poster.
The first half of 1997 inexplicably saw a pair
of volcano-themed films flow through theaters. In
fact, they were practically released on top of one
another, with "Dante's Peak" arriving in February
and "Volcano" following in April. Though neither
of the two proved to be a true winner over the
other, both succeeded in providing plenty of the
fiery mayhem you'd hope for from a volcano flick.
In "Dante's Peak," a dormant volcano near
a small Washington town is on the brink of
eruption. The catch? No one but Pierce Brosnan's
seasoned scientist Harry Dalton seems convinced
of the impending cataclysm, with his doomsday
predictions falling on deaf ears. Meanwhile,
a budding relationship between Harry
and the town's mayor — played by Linda
Hamilton — complicates matters, and gives him
a personal stake in the community's future.
Dialing up the explosive action to 11, it's
not a small town that comes under peril in
"Volcano," but the entirety of Los Angeles.
When violent earthquakes disturb a previously
unknown volcano beneath the streets of L.A.,
it sends lava spewing throughout the streets,
causing untold destruction. While neither
film quite managed to become a classic,
both are fun, exciting adventures that
should definitely satisfy disaster fans.
England's most famous Prime Minister, Winston
Churchill, remains a symbol of British defiance
and one of the most revered leaders of World War
II. Proving that sentiment are a pair of biopics,
"Churchill" and "Darkest Hour," both of which
were oddly released in 2017. Even though both
films follow the same historical figure, they're
fairly distinct in style, tone, and setting.
"Churchill" kicks off in the later
period of Churchill's wartime career,
set amidst the tense days just prior to
the Allied invasion of Normandy. Here,
Churchill is played by Brian Cox, and the
film paints him in an entirely different light
than history has come to remember. Cox portrays
Churchill as a more cautious and vulnerable man,
with reservations about seeing through the
impending assault. It's an intriguing study
of one of history's best-known figures — but
"Churchill" was immediately met with controversy,
as some historians took issue with the depiction
of the Prime Minister as a hesitant commander.
"There are lessons we learned in the last
war. I don't want to make the same mistakes!"
"Of course…"
"And I shall not be stopped
from speaking my mind!"
Released later but set earlier, "Darkest
Hour" takes place during the transition
of power as Winston Churchill takes over for
the outgoing Neville Chamberlain. Meanwhile,
the looming threat of a German invasion of the
British Isles has left the nation in a crisis,
and the newly-elected Churchill
must wrestle with the choice
between total capitulation or continuing the
desperate fight for survival. Ultimately,
"Darkest Hour" proved both more memorable and a
bigger success than its eponymously titled twin,
and Gary Oldman ended up winning an
Oscar for his portrayal of the UK leader.
You've almost certainly seen or at least heard
of "Top Gun," the 1986 hit that launched a
young Tom Cruise to superstardom as Naval
aviator Pete "Maverick" Mitchell. The Cold
War action flick was the top grossing title
of its year, a feat even its surprisingly
successful sequel couldn't pull off some
three decades later. With all that in mind,
it might surprise some to learn that
not only was "Top Gun" competing with
another tale of airborne aces in '86, but
it wasn't even the first to see release.
That's right — beating "Top Gun" to the theaters
by four months was "Iron Eagle," a similar story
of gutsy fighter pilots duking it out in the
skies. It all starts when Doug Masters, Air
Force Academy reject and son of a decorated pilot,
hears that his father has been shot down over the
fictional nation of Bilya. Springing into action,
Doug turns to reservist Colonel and Vietnam
veteran Charles "Chappy" Sinclair to procure
a pair of fighter jets and complete a daring
and unsanctioned rescue of his father. Pushing
the limits of campy, improbable action to the
limit — even for the '80s — "Iron Eagle" defied
its abysmal reception with a trio of sequels,
but none of them came anywhere close to the
billion-dollar mark like "Top Gun: Maverick" did.